[Music]
i would have never
said i slept like that how do you sleep
like that
absolutely
[Music]
let me tell you about alvin's sleeping
habits
i don't tend to snore he tends to snore
i generally stick
to my side of the bed he'll also like
take over the bed like
in terms of how my wife sleeps i want
the air conditioner as low
as it will possibly go the temperature
on the other side of the bed
it's fluctuating all over the place when
it comes to
sheets and blankets if anything is
tucked
i'm not sleeping in it we'll have the
comforter tossed off it comes onto my
side
there's nothing i can do about that in
the middle of the night then i get
accused
of taking all the blankets cheryl i love
you
but i have to put you out there my
sleeping habits consist of
her phone being right next to her she'll
probably be on tick tock and laughing
her butt off
but i try to be really considerate of
alvin who's already sleeping
cheryl also is the type of person who
rolls over a lot so she'll start on her
side and then she'll migrate to my side
i'm like a rock chris is sleeping he
sleeps with his hands floor
okay i fall asleep in some sort of like
cute little adorable fetal position the
most annoying part about
it is how big he is i don't like my feet
and my legs and my limbs outside of the
bed i feel like there's been at least
once where you've kicked fluffy off the
bed uh not alvin
we're going to go ahead and see what
really goes down when the lights go down
what do you think this video is going to
show that you steal did i
steal what the blanket and that you
elbowed me in the head all the time
because
i forgot to say you like to sleep like
this folks
let's send it up to the night vision
camera and let's
settle this once and for all
let's see how we slept
[Laughter]
a little bit so the phone is under the
pillow he's officially trying to fall
asleep
i'm out like a light
[Laughter]
back in full sprinter i don't look
comfortable no you don't
like you look how you would imagine
someone sleeping
look at your mouth a little bit of a
corpse
so suddenly she just decides we're done
with the blankets
oh look how angelico
so cute you're coming on to my territory
now look at your head that's
right at the beam right the middle of
the rock on the beach you [ __ ]
you've been more than over my side you
look so weird
all right well i'm kind of scared to
look at the footage but
let's do it fluffy will be joining us
because he's also
in the film oh my gosh
my eyes why are you you're like a little
baby
dude you wake up a lot no i don't
you just flew in you're like what's
happening we tend to move at the same
time though
like if one moves you the other moves so
it's your fault almost on my side bro
almost isn't your side why are my legs
like that
you realize like all the way out boom
boom side cross and now i gotta go to my
side even more
dude your legs hanging out yeah man
because your overhead is taking that
like more than half the bed
someone's so little takes so much space
i cross my legs
bro what are you doing oh my god i don't
know how i'm bet like
why is my arm doing that how do i lie
how do you sleep like that i don't know
look at you
look at you somebody's staring at you
i don't know why are you staring at me i
want to pee is that how you wake up
yeah that is weird it's what time i woke
up compared to when you wake up two
hours later
we thought we would be basically in full
combat
all night it seems like people stay
more in their lanes which maybe there is
a level
of sleeping respect here despite i think
it was a fluke
i think he knew the camera was on doing
a little show
no way if a show means sleeping like a
swimsuit beach model boy it's more like
this
do you feel like you're gonna be more
self-aware of how you sleep in terms of
habits that annoy me or vice versa
absolutely not
do you get cold at night no not really
why do you do the little
because man i'm comfortable that's
comfortable bro
don't don't talk about how i sleep why
do you sleep like this like all spread
everything bro how's that comfortable i
get a deep stretching at night
you're literally doing yoga and
meanwhile fluffy just over here trying
to figure out where you fits in if you
wanted to see what your significant
other
and you both do while you're sleeping
definitely get a wise camera
we'll put the link down below let the
expose evie
[Music]
get